c'est horrible histoire bien changement
de trip en place au banc test
le blind test arbitré par marcia
philippe corti et ce soir en juillet
j'ai fait les puits
bryce est anjou dément ce soir là vous
connaissez le principe du samedi soir
bonsoir du shopping chez ardisson de joy
fringues mais si c'est un truc de jeunes
alors oui donc le principe est simple je
veux l'interprète et non pas le titre de
la chanson est pour vous aider sachez
que c'est soit consacré un ange soit un
démo la lumière et les ténèbres
exactement didier l'émule de la centrale
roma n'a pas tombé loin
et nous
m
non
bravo tir enroulé la bouée semble bien
alors déjà un point pour joue par équipe
a donc vous m'avez ans les des mangues
marque un point
il dit
hachez les
commencés mardi en ile et non mais non
c'est non et non vous êtes bien pas bien
joué j'avais en moi tout seul expert
n'attend de recherche allait bien didier
numéro 3 le nom du héros
je vous aime
winston sympathie pour le démon les
rolling stones bravo gilles ducos ça ils
s'arrêtent ou web et c'est ça tu vois là
d'accord ok tout concernant moi je
mettrais jamais vu des 4
suivirent des mois je passe je passe
très bien
c'est à dire que j'ai été mal pour eux
mais pour toi c'est pire que ça veut
dire que tout ce que le ghana quatre
essais les grands délits question en
toute sincérité je suis pas baigné edith
piaf et aux stones ah bah oui mais bon
rien dit les mecs qui pensent que je
faisais les camps faire face non le
petit james un petit truc là ça bravo
révélations
est ce qu'on peut avoir du gansu avait
ses fans il à didier
une très belle chanson
on ne souffle pas
jérémy de jeunesse je me soupçonne mais
vous laisser souffler confirmé qu avait
quand même des super honnête c'est
vraiment honnête moi ouais mais c'est
bien c'est le monsieur labaki oui ils
vont bien trouver un mois j'ai répété ce
calibre mais j'étais devant j'ai vu
combien êtes vous étonné tout si on le
compare didier 7
le souverain viable et d'une valeur
d'une marque à bas prix du bel air
quelle belle idée que c'est lui
il a maintenant le regard de bambou l'a
vécu trés neige est assez sûr de boubous
rien vous l'avez trouvé tout de suite ça
on peut voler avec les ennemis qu'on
peut voler attention
vous connaissez bien
une astuce ordination de la noblesse
vous reprenez jeunes
quand même lancé une soirée disco donna
donc c'est romain dumas c'était à 1,7
quand même un léger pas photo 10 janvier
au japon
supertramp c'est dur ça en même temps si
notre époque
la ville
aller chercher dans le public
essaie de faire maintenant
alors moi je n'ai pas trouvé a précédé
la mission n'a trouvé
damas ap ap
elle vous plaît cette chanson c'est
effectivement aussi des images de bouder
beau alors maintenant on arrive au
superbe en cause donc c'est l'attention
à catane pour 10 entrées vous parce que
le super bowl me sens très injuste de
dire que celui qui se trouve le super
banco même site même si c'est eux qui
trouvent ils ont gagné alors que j'ai
truc où trouver tu vas aimer la vie des
gâchettes il s'agit de néo bleu c'est
comme la vie mais fayyad est bon voilà
des fois ya du bon heureusement je peux
alors voilà donc celui qui trouve le
super banco ramassamy si vous trouvez
pas le super banco
c'est ce qu'ils ont gagné qui continuent
à gaza l'interprète
lebron
bien entendu
axel ce soir c'est vous qui attend ça
veut dire que le super banco est annulée
à cause de tout
la prochaine fois je l'évacué la salle
je vois tu as volé je voulais faire je
me posais voilà donc on en reste au
sénat s'est détériorée me trouvais ça
non
le long des rues laurier aupa bo
s'appelle il est mal canal la saison
mais ne bougeait pas tu peux me lâcher
pourquoi cette pression sur moi comme ça
se permet de juger sont tous l'absolu
alors danser et news corp est ce qu est
ce que quelqu'un que vous ce domaine a
eu lieu sur la seule personne donc on en
reste d'autres plans précédents
on applaudit visible et messieurs les
membres
mais diable
voilà c'était tout le monde en parle
merci à tous laurent baffie sexe
magouille et culture générale
alors on a dit pascal sellem allemand
daniel russo géorgienne boney m
au final romane bohringer les sept jours
de simon avec richaud valls magali vivre
sa vie' ouvert au théâtre hall edgar
degas qui exige de la pièce de tennessee
williams
la ménagerie de beurre 2 septembre les
gens voilà
il parlait merci les menus et prochain
vendée globe ou route du rhum michel en
quarts mémoire vivante aux émissions pas
marion une série d'entretiens avec la
journaliste julie peine comme axelle
laffont clamé séoul du ferme à danser à
sauter le plus haut si gameiro fournir
album solo qui s'appelle réflexion et
loïs siggen dont des tissus qui
s'appelle beach
voilà comme on ne dit rien avec eux le
petit but pour la lie la sphère de
légende aux indiens
rien bon ben on line jean claude blanc
le père michael blanc et du noir est
donc en allant sur le site internet
vous saurez où envoyer vos bons pour
soutenir michaël blanc est bien dans la
merde c'est bien bien condamner la voilà
association de soutien amical lors voilà
c'était le monde en parle
l'émulsion pas comme les jo rendez vous
samedi prochain